[Music]
[Applause]
aha yeah today you will learn English
with Harry Potter and the magical sport
of the Wizarding World Quidditch and if
you're new here every single week we
make fun lesson just like this one so
that you can learn to understand fast
speaking natives without getting lost
without me some the jokes and without
subtitles krishna says that he feels
like he's finally learning that you wish
that natives really speak and you will -
all you have to do is hit that subscribe
button and the button below so you don't
miss any of our new lessons
[Music]
Quidditch is easy enough to understand
each team has seven players three
chasers two beaters one keeper and the
seeker that's you there are three kinds
of balls this one's called the Quaffle
no the chasers handle the Quaffle and
try to put it through one of those three
hoops a keeper that's me
defends the hoops with me so far I think
what are those you better take this
[Music]
careful knows coming back a bad Potter
you'd make a fair beater
[Music]
what's that
blodger nasty little buggers but you not
a seeker
the only thing I want you to worry about
is this the Golden Snitch like this bull
yeah you like it no just wait
it's wicked fast and damn near
impossible to see what do I do with it
you catch it before the other teams
seeker you catch this the game is over
you catch this Porter and we win
[Music]
footage is easy enough to understand
each team has seven players three
chasers two beaters one keeper and the
seeker
so Quidditch is a sport full of specific
terms and names some of the words are
completely made-up that is they don't
make any sense in real knowledge other
words actually mean something and can be
interpreted without much of an
explanation
so Wood says that every Quidditch team
is made up of seven players being
divided into three chasers two beaters
one keeper and the seeker that's you
there are three kings of balls this
one's called the Quaffle no the chasers
handle the Quaffle and tried to put it
through one of those three hoops so he
explains that players called the chasers
handle the ball named the Quaffle and
try to score points by putting it
through the hoops a hoop is a large ring
of wood metal or similar material like a
basketball hoop or the piece that holds
a barrel together to handle something in
this case is to hold and control
something with the hands check out this
example No
you do know well
and the word chaser comes from the verb
to chase if you are chasing someone or
chasing after someone you are following
them quickly in order to catch or reach
them start the van
[Music]
hey now the chasers handle the Quaffle
and try to put it through one of those
three hoops keeper that's me
defends the hips so would tells Harry
that he plays the keeper position
[Music]
the keeper much like the goalkeeper or
goalie in some real sports such as
soccer and hockey is the player
responsible for defending the goal area
and stopping the other team from scoring
[Applause]
what are those you better take this
you better is an idiom meaning should or
need to especially when advising someone
to do something so you better take this
literally mean something like it would
be better if you took this
[Applause]
it is actually a colloquial way to say
you have better after contracting the
word had so normally proper English
would require you to say or write
you'd better however the way the D in
huge sounds went said against the B and
better mix it almost inaudible you can
barely hear it as a result many English
speakers end up saying and even writing
you better
a bad Potter
you'd make a fair beater the player
called beater does exactly what Harry
just did they beat the bludger ball with
a bat so we here Oliver say that Harry
would make a fair beater
although the adjective fair is mostly
used in the sense of justice he can also
refer to the level of quality of
something or somebody
meaning ordinary or acceptable example
the movie wasn't great but it wasn't bad
either
I thought the actors gave a fair
performance of your strength I don't
know I can fly I'm a fast flyer but I
better than fair the way I heard it so a
wood is saying that Harry would make a
fair beater he could play as a beater
and it wouldn't be that bad above
average a bad Potter
you'd make a fair beater in Quidditch
the butcher is a heavy ball that
magically moves to the air by itself as
if it were alive trying to hit and knock
down players
[Music]
hey do you want to learn the vocabulary
that you actually need to understand
natives and communicate confidently well
we have a really fun way for you to get
it with our fluent with friends course
in this forty eight week course you will
learn thousands of words and expressions
that natives actually use in everyday
conversation alongside the first two
seasons of the TV series friends with
twenty plus page PDF power lessons
vocabulary memorization software access
to a floozy circle global community and
so much more and you can try it for free
right now with our three-part master
class just click up here or down
Sturgeon below to learn more and sign up
even though this is a made-up word from
the Wizarding World it reads and sounds
similar to the verb to bludgeon meaning
to hit someone hard and repeatedly with
a heavy weapon so would informally cause
the bludgers nasty little buggers
butchered nasty little buggers in this
sense the adjective nasty refers to
something or somebody that behaves in a
bad or very unpleasant way that is
dangerous unkind or violent
[Applause]
I didn't expect you to do it the first
time I would have been remarkable here
this you feel better that's one nasty
Dementor bugger is a slang expression
used to refer to a silly or annoying
person animal or thing okay just a cat I
don't know we're just a cat we're
alright we'll go upstairs let's look
upstairs come on
oh god damn it
Jesus how many cans do they have it's
the same one I think really yeah quick
little bugger huh but you not a seeker
so the player known as the seeker is the
one responsible for chasing after and
catching the Golden Snitch ball
to seek is to try to find or get
something especially something that is
not a physical object like a job or an
opportunity example if you're not
feeling better by the end of the day
seek medical attention before the night
is out he will come to me do you
understand the only thing I want you to
worry about is this the Golden Snitch
finally Oliver introduces Harry to the
ball called the Golden Snitch it is
golden because it's colored like gold or
it's made of gold now the names snitch
in real English comes from the verb to
snitch if you snitch something you steal
it quickly and quietly like this bull
yeah you like it no just wait it's
wicked fast and down mean impossible to
see in this sentence the slang
expressions wicked and Damned function
as adjectives and are used with the same
effect to give emphasis so he is saying
that the Golden Snitch isn't just fast
its weak it fast it's super fast hello
hi deeds it's Pam I am wicked sorry
about last night I just I don't drink
very often
and it isn't simply near impossible to
see it's damn near impossible to see
what do I do with it you catch it before
the other teams seeker you catch this
the game is over have you heard the
popular gaming expression game over
although most English learners know of
these words many don't actually
understand the meaning of the word over
in this collocation in this application
if something is said to be over it is
finished it has reached that end so you
can actually collocate it with any other
noun you would like to not just with
sports games for example you can say
that the movie is over the day is over
or even that you are over something
meaning that you are finished doing
something and will not do it anymore
didn't die in vain
[Music]
but you will because you're wrong
her hot dipping furs for all of us hey
mogul we will make gaining English
fluency like magic for you with all of
our lessons featuring Harry Potter in
this playlist I highly recommend that
you check that out after you finish this
video by clicking up here or down in the
description below Quidditch is easy
enough to understand each team has seven
players three chasers two beaters one
keeper and the seeker that's you there
are three kinds of balls this one's
called the Quaffle now the chasers
handle the Quaffle and try to put it
through one of those three hoops a
keeper that's me
defends the hips with me so far
I thinks what are those you better take
this
[Music]
careful knows coming back a bad Potter
you'd make a fair beater
[Music]
Oh
oh what's that
larger nasty little buggers but you not
a secret
the only thing I want you to worry about
is this the Golden Snitch like this fall
yeah you're like it no this wait it's
wicked fast and damn near impossible to
see
what do I do with it you catch it before
the other team's seeker you catch this
the game is over you catch this Potter
and we win hey thanks so much for
joining me today keep going on your
journey to English fluency with our
Harry Potter playlist and now it's time
to go beyond the classroom and live your
English haha yeah